[Music]
the orp
it's one of the most iconic weapons to
ever grace the fps world
over csgo's long history there have been
many people who have tried to wield the
power
of the mighty green some have been more
successful than
others but then there are those who have
taken it and cs go itself
to whole new heights just before we get
into this video make sure you are
subscribed to the score esports and that
way you will never miss a video
just like this one and with that let's
get into the top 10 best authors
of all time
kicking off our list is the wolf of wall
street himself
chris j wants to try and hold off the
rotations oscar's gone chris isn't up
still in the picture
oh still very much in the round oh chris
he's found three it's down to it two one
two
chris can he close this with an ace oh
my god
chris the wolf of wall street gets an
ace
chris j was a pocket offer for years
during most of his time on mousesports
he let oscar handle the gun
but when chris jay picked up that rifle
he proved exactly why he was so
good pretty big part of the burden that
goes with him flashbang in canon
oh my god he flicked headshots rpk
that is outrageous even when mouse
esports were heavy underdogs chris j
always seemed to be able to bring the
team together around him and the mighty
green to take on the world's best and
most famously at esl one new york
he did just that wants to try and hold
off the rotations oscar's gone chris
isn't up still in the picture
oh still very much in the round oh chris
he's found three it's down to it two one
two
chris can he close this with an ace oh
my god
all right up next we have the one and
only skedaddy at the number nine spot
on our list he needed somebody else to
stay alive and that just hasn't happened
the molotov he's going to challenge him
the hero
daddy's here for the triple skadoodle
will probably go down as one of ma's
greatest offers and there's a good
reason for that
there's the peak from happy all the
adjustment skadoodle turns it into a one
on one
he's able to turn it around nine hp
and happy misses that kill and puts rpk
into such a tough spot and this is
patience the time is low
seven seconds five seconds searching for
the kill on skadoodle
just hiding here's the footsteps and
he's trying to buy the time and he does
it
despite the fact that na was a joke for
most of cs go's existence
from 2014 to 2016 skadoodle stood out
and went scoped to scope against some of
europe's best with an
incredibly consistent turret style
stewie's pulled it back now it's just
too remaining
and it's low hp on the two mouse sports
players but speedy gets stewie down
skadoodle countered off in the corner
jumping across feet he's on 13 and
skadoodle's gonna do it
28 kills for skadoodle in the game and
cloud9 is going to a final
but skadoodle's absolute peak came at
the e league boston major
despite being well past his prime
skadoodle had the tournament of his
life taking the trophy over an
indomitable phase clan
and with it the tournament mvp you had
to take down
g2 sk and today you took down faze today
you have made history you are the
e-league major champion
uh thank you thank you um i don't really
have
much words to say as you know i'm not
crying you're crying stop coming in at
number eight is the french prodigy we
all know and love
zaiwoo and steps up three kills to brawl
and and zai will eventually
drop him on the floor but it has to be
the one before clutch from zyward
nearly comes in barely enough health to
survive here on brolin but xavier wants
to kill there's the head shot pulls it
back there's the open side who's got the
triple
krimz is the last man standing and
there's time for the defuse
cyber wants to smoke the bomb if you're
chris you have to be scared
and zombie wins it that is unbelievable
from the young frenchman
look zai wu can basically do it all he
can deagle he can rifle and of course
he can orb but there is a special way
that he uses the orb watch any of his
plays and you'll see his brain working
through the entire map
in the moment every shot this man takes
is a 200 iq
banger i don't know where phase are
coming from they don't know where the
majority is it is ct but there's twist
poking his head out in the toilet so i
will trade another clutch maybe
on the site cold hiding behind the truck
and now zai wu
dancing left and right he's got to pick
his shot wisely he's only got one chance
oh taiwu was considered the best opera
in the world in 2019
and the frenchman has continued to leave
people absolutely
dumbfounded at his play
who better to take the number seven spot
on our list than the guy with the
biggest guns of all
pasha biceps
now these days you might know pasha is a
jack streamer with a heart of gold
but don't let that fool you in his prime
pasha always proved time and time again
why you should never sleep on this
polish order
and that means he can go to work exactly
like this two for him and through the
wall
goes down as well passion might not be
the flashiest player on this list but
he's definitely got the achievements to
back up his placement
and even then pasha is so much more than
his prowess with the mighty green
and that's why we love him
taking the number six spot on our list
is the wonder child himself
jw you're not gonna get that done now jw
though look at this man let's see if we
can do that oh
i was gonna say the beast that we know
him for of course he can it's jw on and
off
my word that is a nice little throwback
to see if you could describe jw's orping
with two words
it would be basha insane the man is just
aggro on a level that no other player
has
ever matched perfect timing there by
apex and now jw decides to go pushing
through apex as the white oh my god
they light up but jw is more than a
madman
he's a three-time major champion
multiple time mvp
and was a pivotal part of what many
consider to be one of the greatest
rosters of all time on fnatic
all on the back of his wacky aggressive
play that still rears its head to this
day
at this point with no player to help him
out you
don't like his chances great shot though
he might be able to get out of here able
to escape down the ladder
now it's on now jw has a chance he's got
some position to work with
looking for a flashbang here he knows
they're closing down in his position
another great connection we talked about
it jw
coming in at the halfway point on our
list is the man who could always come
back from the brink
guardian he's able to catch nico deep
inside of the site the man who i thought
was going to go for the contact play is
suddenly the last alive
oh this is a done round guardian now is
the question as to whether he'll save
the awp good flashbang
could get a couple more out of this one
and fanatic are starting to crumble
what's going on
one player has found three kills
guardian
looking to ace this one out this could
be one of the best rounds of the entire
tournament so far
dumpster that means guardian knows
exactly where to
got low five for most of his career
guardian was considered one of if not
the best sniper in the world with the
ability to decimate teams in the blink
of an eye
that was maybe the only chance but
guardian comes back in oh god if he gets
two
there's still more to go though that
might must pop the ball the peaks come
in but guardian
will not stop one more to go and
guardian
gets them all unfortunately the thing
holding him back from a top four spot on
this list is his
truly awful look at majors guardian has
played in three major finals and won
none of them even when he went super
saiyan at the boston major
guardian just wasn't able to get the dub
despite all that though
guardian set the standard for orpas
everywhere for years and it's a standard
that holds up pretty well
taking the number four spot on our list
is wallen i mean
fallen find the shot in time decent
attempt but not quite enough rush will
be monitored out of the banks has to be
fallen missing another shot there
looking for the wall bank my god he
actually heads it
jokes aside fallen has made his name on
being able to hit
absolutely ridiculous shots that leave
his haters as quiet as a library
seemingly a three on two a five on two
right every single time
still winnable falling needs the ace
clutch he's got two
oh come on fallen yeah the blood's
flowing now
a two-time major winner and a top two hl
tv player
fallen is the most decorated brazilian
player in cs history
and much of that has to do with his
skill on the mighty green
if he does then he is actually just a
god isn't he
trish is nearly shooting him in the side
of the head two more seconds and
it could be over oh
that is so ridiculous that should be
impossible
he's your goat he's my go he's our goat
coming in at number three is
simple you see a double smoke's in the
same place there simple just jumping
casually into the side he's gonna fall
down and get right down
right what is this platform simple are
you serious what is that you can't do
that simple that's not allowed
this is not mpl this is a major
simple might just be the best cs go
player of all time and much of that has
to do with his prowess on the orb
no other player has been able to pull
off more brain melting eye popping spine
breaking plays than
simple yeah was at least jumping i think
so yeah yeah
nasty stuff but simple's gonna get
himself
oh that
is something special and simple would
have taken the number one spot on this
list for free
if it weren't for one small thing he
still hasn't won a major
of course that just means he needs to
pull off a few more insane plays to
finally earn that win and cement his
legacy
14 seconds they've got to get out simple
gets only one in return
jumps up and somehow finds sergey but he
hasn't found the bomb he will now
and he goes away from default because he
doesn't want to get naked he also knows
there's a flank and he also knows he
needs position
he actually gets the first one he's got
a chance he knows al who's up close
and he's around oh that's what we like
from
simple taking the runner-up spot on our
list is mr consistent himself
device those fights are about to come
over device is even here to help out
now while it is good for one they give
it the respect to get back to the car
that might be their undoing
the short play now from twists oh device
reads it in with the flick
burning alive and the collateral in the
flames
device is the most decorated player in
cs history
and much of his success comes from the
fact that he is the most reliable
consistent and downright monstrous
author ever
now is the time and guardian picks up
the first kill spraying his kirby but he
can't make it work there on the bomb
side with just a couple of seconds
device will get the kill there oh my god
are you kidding me a second one comes in
flame he goes down through the box no
seriously device simply doesn't miss
he plays such a stable powerful style
but it's almost the opposite of the
flashy offers you've seen on this list
but it's this style that won him four
majors and 18
hl tv mvps really rough game flashed
he's gonna get that shot and that has to
feel a little bit going out middle of
the air
to take down alex and now they're
pushing oh
he takes every single one
taking the top spot on our list is the
one and only kenny s
i have some uh angry ninjas in his face
very soon
oh that is fast
if you want to know what it feels like
to have a dev patch a game with the sole
purpose of nerfing you
ask kenny s i'm just looking at it and
he wins these
although he's gonna get pushed in this
and he's gonna die oh my god
oh my god no
kenny s's performance with europe is
almost mythical
the man could single-handedly carry
games with a team that had no business
winning anything his place was so
ridiculous that valve had to nerf the
orb so his high speed play style
wouldn't work anymore
but that didn't stop kenny from winning
a major he manages to get out of this
post position picks up the frag onto
aloo goes for the quick second shot
forest is causing oh my goodness so much
damage done here by kenny yes another
frag found and again
kenny s four kills in a row to this day
kenny s is still taking names with
flashy incredible plays that just don't
look
possible and he's built up a huge trophy
case while doing it
despite valve's best efforts the legend
of kenny s
still lives on and just like that
we come to the end of our list obviously
there are so
many good authors out there and i know
that some of you will have watched this
and thought why wasn't this person on
the list
well let us know in the comments also
let us know what you want to see next on
the channel
thanks for watching and i'll see you all
in the next one
i'm gonna kick him
move it
oh my god can yours
man i'm kenneth let's go